the u.s and the world mark and mourn a
milestone in the coronavirus pandemic
a total of one million lives around the
globe
have been lost to covet 19 the disease
caused by the new coronavirus
the virus began spreading like wildfire
six months ago
a pandemic of people pain
and sadly politics and it comes as the
world marks another
important moment the 75th anniversary of
the united nations
today u.n secretary general antonio
guterres
lamented that the pandemic has revealed
humanity's
shortest of shortcomings our
unwillingness to work
together and to help each other
1 million dead are one million too many
but just as the author ernest hemingway
conveys in his book
it is the value of human life which we
must remember when we are reminded
for whom those bells toll here in europe
the most dire warning came today from
the uk
as the disease spreads as it spreads
across
age groups we expect to see
increase in hospitalizations and
unfortunately
those increase in hospitalizations will
lead to an increase in deaths
the epidemic is doubling
roughly every seven days and you can see
that by mid october
if that continued you would end up with
something
like 50 000 cases in the middle of
october per day
yeah disturbing numbers there to talk
about that
let's cross to carlisle in the uk i want
to bring in dr john campbell
dr campbell works as an independent
health analyst he has generated a
sizable following on social media dr
campbell it's good to have you back on
the day thank you let's talk about these
numbers the uk's top health advisors say
that the virus is in general circulation
doubling every seven days and then there
is this other number
50 000 cases per day by next month
if nothing is done i mean these are
these are
sobering figures but they are they are
very high figures i mean the official
increase in cases today was just about
four and a half thousand in the uk
but that was the officially tested cases
that have been formally diagnosed
the office for national statistics is
currently saying about 6 000 new cases
per day
but that means about 70 000 people
suffering from the condition
at the moment today in in the united
kingdom
but the covered symptom tracker act with
the tim spector and zoe group is
probably the most accurate
and that shows over 10 000 new cases
today and nearly 100 000 people
who are actually ill as we are today and
as you rightly say we've got a doubling
time of seven to eight days now i think
that figure of 50 000 new cases per
day patrick valance was keen to point
out that that was what could happen
it's not a projection it's a possibility
he's pointing out a risk
he's pointing out a danger and of course
our job is to make sure that doesn't
happen because it doesn't get to those
kind of levels
because if it did a month later that
would transpire into about 200 deaths
per day and with all of that
you've got prime minister boris johnson
do to address the nation
tomorrow do you think there is pressure
on him to announce a complete lockdown
no i don't really think that's going to
happen now people are talking about the
possibility of a circuit breaker
and a circuit breaker is this idea of a
short sharp
shock where you would have a lock down
only for about two weeks
but i think there's a few reasons why
that probably won't be announced
it takes at least um three three weeks
for the
effects to feed through so you wouldn't
know if it was working
and for that to be effective you'd have
to be locked down for about twice as
long
as you were unlocked so you'd be in this
alternating cycle of of short sharp
shocks of circuit breakers alternating
with normal periods of time
and we're looking about the next six
months of that so i don't think that's
going to happen
but we are getting this exponential rise
for now the the cases are doubling
regularly
so i think we could see increased fines
for breaches
i think it's possible we'll see more
rules on masks and more strict
enforcement of mask wearing
i think there'll be targeted
interventions where he targets
geographical groups
and targets particular types of behavior
that are known to be infection drivers
there's a cobra meeting tomorrow they're
going to decide this there's probably
going to be more public education
one of the infection drivers in the uk
has been late night drinking
so i'm pretty sure that tomorrow we're
going to see a 10
p.m curfew on pups pubs will be closed
at 10 p.m
the risk there of course is people will
go in from the pub and carry on drinking
at home
we couldn't see further instructions on
the on the hospitality
industry as well i don't think schools
and universities are going to be
affected yet
where are we going uh dr campbell i mean
we've got winter
just around the corner you know for the
uk for the united states as well as
for us here in germany what does that
mean
does it mean in your opinion that we've
got
harder times coming for us
the simple answer to that brett is
absolutely yes we know that all
respiratory viruses spread more in the
winter
and people get cold noses so their
infection is reduced
people go inside and shut the window so
there's more
viral load in the air people don't go
out and get as much sunshine so there's
less vitamin
d circulating in the blood and all these
things can contribute towards spread of
infection
there's also the possibility of
influenza although we've got a very
active influenza program going at the
moment
but the next six months are going to be
critical the chief medical officer that
today said we've turned a corner
and really we've got a fork in the road
now we can decide which way to go
one way is that we could have this
exponential rise with cases doubling
the other way is we can get on top of
this virus and keep it managed over
winter
but whatever happens we are going to
have to be taking
all of the measures that we're taking
now for at least the next six months
now i believe a vaccine is coming and i
believe that vaccine will be effective
and i think it's quite possible that a
few key workers
could be vaccinated in vaccinated in
december 2020
but most people are not going to get
this vaccine until 2021
so we've got this winter to get over and
it's this seasonal effect
this seasonal increase in risk as we
shut the doors as we reduce the
ventilation as we turn on the heating
that we're going to get increased
transmission dr kim i've got about a
minute left i want to ask you about this
case of a man in delaware
being reinfected after having recovered
from covet 19 back in march
what does this tell us about the virus's
ability to mutate and what does that
mean
for a vaccine good question
the virus does mutate but it tends to
mutate fairly slowly
it's not a fast mutating virus like an
influenza virus for example
in terms of the the vaccine the people
that are making the vaccine are aware of
the parts of the virus that can mutate
quickly
and they've actually targeted parts of
the virus which are likely to mutate
slowly
and they've also targeted several parts
of the virus so even if one part does
mutate they should still be able to get
the uh
the vaccine working on the other part in
terms of reinfection yes there are
definite documented cases of reinfection
but very very few only about half a
dozen around the world that have
definitely been documented
so people can become reinfected but this
is going to be the vast minority of
cases
and the people that are reinfected don't
get sick they just test positive so far
from the cases i've known so i believe
that when people have been infected with
this disease they do have a
fairly high degree of immunity we don't
know for how long
but i suspect given that size
coronavirus one
showed long-term immunity in some cases
this is likely to as well i'm hopeful
for that
okay dr john campbell as always dr
campbell we appreciate your time and
your
valuable insights tonight thank you
thank you
well now to france which reported a new
record high this weekend with over 13
000 new covet cases in 24 hours
the government wants to avoid returning
to full lockdown
and instead is banking on physical
distancing and other measures to keep
public life
from taking over now for students
returning to the university
the restrictions come with their own
challenge as dw's lisa lewis reports
it's a start of term like no other at
this university in a suburb north of
paris
despite the strict anti-covet measures
these economic students are happy to be
here
it's nice to be back at university this
just shows that despite the virus
life continues our university has done
what's needed to adapt to the situation
we are split into two groups and have
online classes every second week
every second seat is off limits and we
have to wear masks
although that's a bit of a nuisance
quite a contrast to a holiday season
during which many people lowered their
guard
most of france's recent covet cases are
amongst young people
many of us travel during the summer
after all the virus is less severe for
us young
and if many need to get it to build up
heard immunity
the young should get it
the government has only given basic
guidelines to the universities
each institution has had to come up with
its own detailed plan
ours includes masks social distancing
online classes and we have forbidden
student parties
because of these measures we won't have
to shut down if students test positive
for covet because there are no
contact persons at least at university
but the number of infections has been
rising across france
more than half of the country has now
been declared a red zone with at least
15 new daily infections per 100
000 people compared to just a dozen in
neighboring germany
local governments can impose additional
measures in these zones
like temporarily closing baths and
restaurants
and yet social distancing and locally
adapted strategies
won't be enough to prevent another
lockdown says
this virologist
france doesn't even have a testing
strategy for example to test those who
work with vulnerable people such as the
elderly
the only way to control the epidemic is
to systematically track down
and isolate infected people for that we
need to come up with a national strategy
use the most simple testing methods such
as self-testing and group testing and
we need to test massively ensuite
massive despite the challenge the
country faces
these students hope the economy will
stay open they'd like to continue to
enjoy parisian cafe terraces where the
risk of infection is lower
this is like a little patch of paradise
we can meet our friends here without
masks and have a drink
we need to stay united in these hard
times it's important to stay in touch
and form social bonds even if it's just
through meeting up
in small groups it's not certain this
pleasure will last for very long though
the country's strategy does allow for
local lockdowns
and paris has one of the highest
infection rates in the country
and here's a look now at some of the
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the u.s public health body the cdc has
withdrawn guidance saying that fine
aerosol particles floating in the air
may spread the virus the retraction has
sparked concern of political
interference
mexico has passed 700 000 confirmed
coronavirus cases but officials say that
the overall
infection rate is still slowing down and
new zealand recorded
zero new covid19 infections on tuesday
there are now
only 61 registered active cases in the
country